Hey,
what's going on is bill burn is time for
the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
October 10th,
2016 Jesus Christ.
Holy Shit.
That's what,
who else yelled at near Knoxville,
Tennessee when they'd running back
fumbled the ball and your quarterback is
trying to, God bless them. It's
trying to pick the ball up.
Why won't they fall on the fucking ball?
Everybody's just like, oh, I can
pick it up and then run with it.
Just fall the fucking thing.
It's not,
it's the shape of the fucking ball too.
Even if you fall on it,
it somehow fucking squirts out. Oh,
he'd die. 1,000 deaths is three. I was,
this street thinks that have probably
brought me closer as far as sports goes,
just generally speaking,
week after week,
like a bad cigarette or
drinking fucking problem. Right.
The three fucking plays that get me.
I don't know what gets you.
I don't pretend to know who you are and
I would never speak to me however I am
willing to share with you or
what the fuck did I just do?
There it is. Sorry. I swear
to God, I can't get this
fucking thing to do anything,
but if I brush up against anything,
the whole fucking screen disappears.
You don't need people who suck at playing
video games. You know what I mean?
If you play playing like
one of those five games,
the other guy's kicking your ass.
You just start fucking hitting a million
of them and all of a sudden like these,
these clouds started forming around
your guy and he does a little fucking,
I dunno, spinning back fist with his foot,
whatever the fuck that's called. Right.
Um, that's what it happens to me
with computers. And then I then I,
you never know how you just did
it. Everybody was like, Oh shit,
what the fuck is that? I don't, I don't
know. So anyways, the three things,
how's this for controlling my add?
I'm going to stick with this year.
The three going to get back to it.
The three fucking things
that just make me die.
1,000 deaths is deaths.
Plural. Yes. Is um,
cause 1000 is more than
one. Stay on target, Bill.
Stay focused is not falling on a fumble,
dropping, you know, catching a
fucking ball run into the end zone,
returning upon returning to kickoff,
running with the fucking bank.
Banks rarely do this.
It's always fucking receivers
and people who returned kicks,
I think they called kick returners
for whatever fucking reasons. Reason.
I don't understand why
these motherfuckers,
they get to write to the goal
line and then they booked.
They just drop it right on the half
yard line as if they bet the under.
That kills me.
Like how many?
Like you would think like the first time
you saw somebody do that, you'd be like,
Oh my God, I'm never fucking,
that's not going to be me.
I'm going to run to the back
of the fucking end zone.
Then I'll fucking spike it.
I'll drop it. I'll do my little fucking
moonwalk. Whatever the fuck it is.
All right. The freckled,
Fandango, whatever. My end
zone dance would be called.
I mean on Fandango means, I just know
it's an old Kevin Costner movie. Um,
okay.
That and then finally,
My favorite in yours, the prevent
defense. The fucking privilege giveaway.
The Mill,
Allah will give him a fucking 30 yard
cushion and rather than them scoring on us
on one play,
they'll score in five places.
But the amount of clock that they're
going to eat up versus the points that
they're going to score is slowly going to
kill everybody in our fucking fan base.
You know what I mean? It's really
hard to tell him fucking voice.
It's really hard to tell [inaudible]
that I'm not through puberty yet.
It's really hard to tell like truly who
was a great quarterback in the final two
minutes of the game ever since
the prevent defense. Cause I,
I think back in the day,
I mean I know that they didn't
want you to get behind him.
They must have done some
early version of it,
but there was like a few guys that
would go down the field. You know,
you're Roger Star, she, you, Terry
Bradshaw's, Ken Stabler, you know,
but everybody else,
I mean it was like three or four guys
that could do it and now it's just
everybody in the league because it did
just get, I swear to God, you could put,
you could put, I'm going to go
a little Mike and Mike here.
Don't write down. You could put me
under center during the prevent defense.
I could definitely,
I could complete a fucking pass as long
as they didn't know that. It always me.
Okay.
That that was not a
professional quarterback,
that this is actually a podcaster slash
comedian slash a crafter of shit jokes,
you know. Then of course they
just play defense, you know,
they blitz or whatever
the fuck they would do.
But if they gave me the
respect of an NFL quarterback,
I could, I could dump it off. That
shouldn't happen on any fucking level.
So whenever I was watching that,
the Tennessee, Texas a and m game,
what a fucking game.
You know,
I want to say that Tennessee
shot themselves in the
foot with their 58 fucking
turnover was, but you got to
give it up to Texas. I mean,
they just kept making them
happen. You know, I mean,
I want to think that somebody on the
coaching staff or the volunteers said,
hey guys,
what's say we protect the football?
What's say the next time we gained 80
yards on one fucking play on this team,
we talked the thing away,
you know,
put two hands on the fucking ball.
Um, I know that there was saying that
yet the turnover's just kept coming.
You know, it was just, I dunno,
it was fucking him. An amazing
game. And um, I have to tell you,
coming from a professional sports city,
you know,
the safe suburbs, as I always
say, ever since goodwill hunting,
everybody thinks she grew up in southeast.
You stole cars,
you're good at math and you like apples.
That's not me. That's not the guy I am.
I grew up in the safe suburbs.
There was street hockey dad,
there was a,
there was little league baseball.
We had a great place to get ice cream,
you know,
not saying that they weren't
fucking maniacs, you know,
that later got into fight next daily
bid people's ears off cause they were
biting on the air and that guy would go
to push them and then part of the year
would come off. I'm not saying that people
like that did not come from my town.
I'm just saying more so than not, people
did not bite other people's ears off.
Now you getting towards the
downtown area, like the, you know,
who knows what the fuck would happen. All
right. That's all I'm saying. Anyways,
let me get back to this shit.
So, uh, coming from a, uh,
the safe suburbs of a,
of a major fucking city that's
a professional sports city,
um, I, I can't believe that. I
haven't watched called football.
Like I've been watching it since 2007,
so I'm almost a decade in,
but the years that I lost, it's a fucking
travesty. I'd watch it a little bit,
but I have to be honest with you.
If you watch SCC football,
if you watch the Verne
Lundquist Gary Danielson,
if he just watched that game every week.
Okay.
Which is usually a fucking SCC game.
You watch an SCC football game.
I'm telling you the NFL
[inaudible] this time,
this particular time cannot
fuck with those games.
They're unbelievable. They're just
fucking, even even that last week,
that was an ACC game that Clemson
Louisville game was fucking crazy, man.
It kind of helps.
This year somebody was bringing up that
everybody seems to be scoring 30 and 40
points.
Speaking of which,
what the fuck happened to the Oregon
ducks did like the whole school did the
whole team from last year just say,
yeah,
we all want to be eligible for the draft.
I don't know what happened to them.
What's going on with you, Cleo?
You're all fucking itchy. All right.
Just lay down buddy. Lay down. You
don't know how to come up on the couch.
You don't your idea. You can't
just have your part of the couch.
You'd come up here and then you
just feel fucking, you know,
you're all over me. I understand it.
I like it. But I've got a podcast too,
so go lay down buddy. Go lay down
buddy. Go on. There you go. Um,
anyway,
so I ended up watching the Tennessee game,
um, at home in Los
Angeles. Now some of you,
if you listen to this podcast, you're
like, well, wait a minute, Bill.
How the fuck were you at home on Saturday?
And as they say in the Boston area,
why don't you come over on a fucking
Saturday as one little consonant in the,
it's Saturday. Come over.
Well, I don't want to say,
um,
he was supposed to be down
in the swamp at the Florida.
Lsu gained that fucking stadium.
I've wanted to go there since
Emmett Smith played there,
I always loved the colors.
The blue with the orange helmet.
Emmitt Smith was the
shit. It just, I just,
I've wanted to go there for
fucking ever. They've, oh,
they've always had great teams.
Florida football has always been,
it's just my whole, probably since
my teens, when Jimmy Johnson,
how boys came into fucking
University of Miami.
Then you had the other guy there
at Florida state with Billy Bouton,
whatever the fuck his name was,
who couldn't feel goal kickers were always
wide left and wide. Right. You know,
um, I've been wanting to go to that
stadium forever. But of course the, uh,
the hurricane came in and, um, you
know, one of my buddies was saying,
you know, early in that week, like,
like we get so fucking crazy excited
cause that that's like you got,
and you got to have this as,
as, as a guy when you get older,
you have to have that thing that you do.
The guys weekend thing is fucking Coney
as they try to make it sound as much as
it sounds like a fucking beer commercial.
Like those are the things and women should
have them to whatever it is that they
want to fucking go do.
I know it involves wine,
their own way of getting fucked up and
everything and they like, you know,
food and all that shit. Um, I like to
stand out in a parking lot in the elements
eating stuff that I don't really
know, uh, what they put in it,
like hot dogs and that type of shit.
So anyways,
we get so excited to go to this fucking
game. Uh, my buddy got the tickets,
somebody else handled the, uh, the, the
fucking car service ticket over there.
And uh, I went out and I got the, I
got the cigars. All right. I came in,
they loaded for bear. I got
to hook up. I'm not going to
say, oh, whatever, whatever.
I had some fucking sticks.
All right.
I had some fucking just picture every
fucking brand of Cuban cigars that,
you know,
Cohibas party gets partake in
over the fuck you say it. Tomato,
tomato. I had mono. Christos, I just,
I had some fucking tremendous
sticks and I brought it up.
There was five of us. I was brought,
I brought 15 Cuban cigars, right?
We could eat smoke one every fucking
night and each one was going to get
progressively more insane.
Start with the mild one Thursday go
a little medium and then the fucking,
you know, we just, I dunno, we
just fucking won a world war.
That's the one you got a smoke
on the game day game, right.
So the beginning of the week we're all
fucking amped up with texting each other
and everything. And then my buddy
who lives on the east coast,
cause every on the west coast,
we don't pay attention to the east coast.
You fucking get up three hours before we
do. By the time we have a cup of coffee,
that day's half over. There is no, there's
no point of even reading the newspaper.
Everything has already
progressed like another 12 hours.
So I didn't pay attention and
my buddy texted me, he goes, uh,
there would have to be a fucking
hurricane this weekend. And I was like,
get the fuck Outta here.
Right in the game plan was we were
flying into Atlanta and like assholes. I,
we booked US Atlanta.
We were doing a Gig and then we were
going to Gainesville to do the show,
but like assholes,
we didn't book hotels until
the last second and already
100,000 people coming in
to see the fucking game. There was no
hotels. So guess where we got our hotels?
Take a wild guess what?
Florida city.
We got our hotels rooms,
Jacksonville, Florida.
That's where we were going to go.
So we were going to fly down from
Atlanta and then pick up a rental car,
drive over to Gainesville, do
the gig Friday night, drive back,
drop off the rental car, go back
to the hotel, smoke another stick.
Fucking jumped in the car service.
Go over there and see fucking a legendary
football program and the greatest
conference that's out
right now. The Sec, right?
So I hear the hurricane's coming,
so I got right. You know what?
They're probably going to cancel
bunch of flights. Fuck this.
So I get a rental car. I get
a rental car. I'll clear.
Please don't puke on the rug. Do you need
to go outside, buddy? What are you doing?
Huh? Was that just you or was
that me? That was you. You okay?
Don't step on the recording,
cleo.
God dammit. Just sit down. Just
sit down. Just sit down please.
Can you please sit down? Sorry
guys. Anybody else's dog? Eat Grass.
And even if they're not failing,
even if they're feeling well,
they just fucking eat grass.
Why do you do that, Cleo?
Huh?
Sometimes you've just talked to them.
They get so focused on you and they
put the rose up. No, no. Go lay down.
Go lay down. Do you need to go upstairs?
You want to go see mommy? All right.
Hang on a sec.
Hang on one sec. All
right. Can I go see mom?
Hold on.
Oh,
that was a great one for us,
but she did a few picked up something.
There it goes. That sock. Alright. Anyway,
so that was the game plan. So I was like,
all right. So you know they're,
they're going to be overly cautious.
They're going to cancel the
fucking flights and Baba Baba Baba.
So we'll just fucking drive down. Well,
everybody's leaving the hurricane.
We're going to fucking drive
down the 75 south. Well,
so we fucking land and uh,
they're supposed to make
a decision Thursday at one
o'clock and they don't make
a decision.
So me and Bart,
nick around the fucking or in the lobby
more excited that they didn't make a
decision like, yeah, dude, come on man,
this is fucking, this is the south.
They're playing this fucking game.
They're playing the game. They don't,
they don't want to cancel this fucking
game and have to fuck him or refund
100,000 tickets and try to figure out
when to reschedule their fucking plane.
And we got excited and we had hope and
then the whole fucking thing it, it,
you know, it went up to a category
for it and all fucking went to,
went to shit.
But I got to tell you actually,
if I was even trying to
drive down to the south,
like they evacuated so many people
smartly, by the way. I mean,
only three people died in a category
for, well you know, down in Haiti,
like you know, a couple of hundred,
they said even more died. Uh,
granted we're first world, we have
better structures and that type of shit.
But you know, back in the day,
I mean that would have been us.
Like I was thinking about that
back in the day. Like you know,
when you didn't know a hurricane was
coming, I mean you saw like signs,
but like by then you only had like six
hours to try and get the fuck out of
there.
What am I trying to say?
Long story short is even
if we try to drive south,
they just completely closed off
the southbound 75 at some point.
And it was just like all of Florida
driving up so it didn't work out.
So then we were like, okay, how do we
save this weekend? Because my buddy,
the one who told us about the fucking
hurricane, he had not even left yet.
So he's at home with his wife and
his kids. He's a total family man.
In once a year he goes out, you know,
has some beer, smokes a stick. It's just,
you know,
and he goes,
this was the one weekend where his
kids didn't have any sports. All right,
we got to make it happen for this guy.
So we started looking around,
where the fuck can we go? The
Georgia bulldogs home? No,
there in South Carolina. South Carolina
is three and a half hours away.
Let's fucking drive to that one.
And then we find out it got fucking moved
to Sunday. Fuck. Can't go to that game.
What else do we got?
UNC?
I just went to UNC and I want to watch
him play Notre Dame. Notre Dame stinks.
Or is that NC state? NC state was
playing them. I was like, look dude,
I'm not driving into the fucking
Carolina. It's the God. Damn.
The fucking storm is coming up that
way. All right. What about Tennessee?
Let's go to the voluntary.
Well, do it right.
Let's go to where all fuck.
We're in a panic.
Who's Tennessee play at
Texas a and M Aggies.
Great fucking game where they
play in college station. Fuck.
All right. Who's next?
Who's next to Alabama,
where they play, who they played
with it. They're playing Arkansas.
Where they playing in Arkansas.
Alright. Auburn, Auburn war.
Eagle War Eagle. Who Do
they got? Who they got?
Mississippi state is sippy state where
they play it. Auburn, Mississippi state.
It was just three of us standing at this
fucking over the sports page trying to
salvage this fucking weekend
looking everybody was a way,
the only way to get to any of the games
that we wanted to go to that worn in the
path of the fucking hurricane was
that we were going to have to fucking,
you know, we were like Clemson, what
about Clemson? They playing BC. Ah,
they're going to kill them.
Were they playing Boston College?
Shack's right over and over and over.
Right.
So the only way we're going to get to
them as if we fucking, uh, you know,
I don't know if we jumped on a plane
and I was already not working the next
night, so we're just going
to hang in Atlanta, then
jump on a plane. It was just,
it got to be too fucking crazy. But
for half a second, we did consider, um,
we did consider the Alabama
Arkansas game, but, uh,
so it didn't end up
happening. But, um, you know,
what do you, what the fuck are
you going to do? It was still,
it was still great to, you know,
it was cool when I got home,
I got to chill with my wife and I got
to watch all those great games and, um,
I didn't have to be in the
path of a fucking hurricane.
I wasn't another asshole that the poor
fire department had to try to fucking,
because I didn't listen to their
warnings, you know what I mean? And, uh,
so anyways, um, Jesus Christ,
that stone was fucking nasty men.
My condolences to anybody down in
the Jacksonville area, you know,
I hope you made it out.
All right.
As far as I think pretty much people
made it out. But I hope your stuff is,
our rec has, God knows those fucking
insurance companies, you know,
they just, Oh yeah, we don't
cover that. If you see that shit,
that one that spike Lee made
about New Orleans where they,
like they just were looking at the
waterline will cover anything below the
waterline there. Like anything
above it, it's your fault.
It's just like you mother fucker
Chris Mad. Like why, why,
what kind of people are
you, you know, I dunno.
Anyways, so can you tell him most of the
typing in my password here? So anyways,
oh,
I got,
I got some more iPhone stories for you
now at a time for a quick iPhone story.
So I got the iPhone seven
now. All right. And uh,
I want to thank everybody who tried to
help me out with even the condescending
ones or this new generation people
who were saying they were cringing.
Me and my boy had to tweet. My boyfriend
works at the apple store or an,
I work at the apple store too.
And we both cringing as we were
listening to you talk about like, why,
why are you see you're cringing from,
I wouldn't cringe for you. Like,
if I watched you two geniuses,
tried to change a fucking tire,
I drive a stick shift as they say you
millennials can't do. If that's the truth,
I wouldn't crunch.
I tried to teach you how to do it
cringing. I felt so bad. I was so odd.
I really think this whole generation of
the reason why they're always using that
term awkward is because they
were so sheltered that I
don't think that they kind
of work shit out amongst themselves
as kids the way we did. Now,
granted my generation was
too far the other way.
They didn't know what the fuck we were
doing. And I think what millennials,
there was an overcorrection.
I think this next generation they're going
to get it right. It's like, you know,
he can't have him fucking
join. You know, the,
those groups where there's
all these pedophiles, you
know, you know what they are.
I am not going to say him. One rhymes
with, with the, uh, the rubs louts
the rub shouts.
You also don't want to,
when they're very young, it's
probably not good to have them take a,
uh, I can't even say it,
right. A Herati class,
um, you know, shit like that.
They're the kinds of places and
then you can just say church groups,
church groups, and one of the big one, you
just, you just can't have them fucking,
you know,
but you have to let him play outside.
You got to let him solve Shit,
you know,
interact with each other and shit
like that. Like, you know what I mean?
Like I think we went too far the other
fucking direction and I can say that
having never had a child.
So anyways,
um, somebody told me
that, you know, when I,
when I sat there and counted all
my contacts, I didn't realize,
and this is all shit that you
guys can laugh at me about,
but I know there's a lot
of you, especially in my
generation, do not know this.
If you scroll down to the
end of your contacts, it'll
tell you how many you have.
Um, I was off by one, I said one 13. I
had one 14 who knew who the fuck knew.
Um, I, and by the way, if
you didn't use the cloud, uh,
getting all your contacts back,
not a big deal, not a big deal.
It's just as you need the person's
number. You're like, fuck,
I don't have the number. Who Do I know
that knows him? He just, you know,
by then you have that person's number and
you gradually put it all back together
again. It's so, it wasn't
as bad as I thought.
And then somebody gave me
a great suggestion and say,
well, there's, there's, uh,
these places you can go to that they,
they can retrieve lost data
or whatever the fuck that,
whatever the computer term is that.
So I might try that with my phone.
I have not turned it on since then.
I'm going to try sometime
like Tuesday morning,
hope that I can turn it
on and grab a couple. Um,
you know, the guy who used to work on
my truck, he moved to Arizona and uh,
he recommended this great
place here in California,
the tune it up and all that type of shit.
And I lost his fucking number
and cause he's a crazy car guy.
Like his website's still has
like a fucking California number,
so I should probably just give it
a try. But anyway, so, so anyways,
so I had to get the iPhone seven cause I,
I fucked up my phone.
I've got it all wet and shit. And
um, so now this one's waterproof,
so they had this little fucking
umbilical cord off of it.
And I was sitting there going,
there's no fucking way,
I'm not going to lose this thing. I have
to be on my best behavior with this.
So I was literally carrying that little
cord around in the iPhone box with me
while I was on the road because I was
too paranoid to even leave it into the
phone. Cause I was afraid I'd go to
put my pocket pop out. I wouldn't know.
I don't know what. So, um,
I somehow make it across this country
and back. I still have it. Um,
I went back to my house to use my gym,
you know,
I said finishing up the
fucking kitchen, you know, um,
and I had it there and I went to
grab a few things and I dunno,
I get back to the place that I'm renting
and it was just gone. It was gone.
And I started to have a meltdown and I
was just like this drive, she wife nuts,
don't do it, don't fucking do
it. And I tore apart everything,
couldn't find it in the house.
I drove back to my place,
I couldn't find it there and I just said,
fuck this.
And I drove over to the apple store and
somewhere over there I just got into
this fucking zen place. I was like,
dude, this is 100% your fault.
It's not Steve jobs fault.
It's your fault.
You should just left the
fucking thing in your phone.
I'm sure you can pick up the phone and
fucking shake it. And I'm sure nothing,
you know,
I'm sure it probably doesn't even come
out cause they'll probably already knew
that that was going to be a fucking
concern. So I drive over there, you know,
I pull in,
I just said fuck it.
I valet my old Prius dirty as shit right
now because I still have to get the
dense taken off from that fucking
road rage. Cunt slammed in the person,
two people behind me. Um, so I
just got that thing has got dense,
I'm going to get pulled out. Why get it
washed? So it's, it's really looking bad.
So I pull in and the valley place at
the mall, they go like, yeah, what's,
what's your phone number? And I'm just
like, yeah, none of your business. I go,
I don't give out my phone number. That's
what I used to say. Now I just go,
I don't have a phone cause they're just
going to call you. And it's just, it,
just all of those things,
by the way,
all of those phone numbers and
all of that Shit, I'm telling you,
it all gets bundled and it gets,
it gets sold. There was a lobby,
there was something, a
lobby, there was something,
something going on in Washington where
they, what, what they were saying.
What I was saying much more intelligently
and written down on paper saying that
you ought to get a piece
of it and something's going
to sell your information.
Shouldn't you get a cut?
Right. 10% something.
I'm sure that got shot down. But anyways,
uh, so I just pulled up and I just say,
yeah,
I don't have a cell phone.
So then they just take your name down
and there's always ways to get around it.
You just say, yeah, no
I can't do that. Right.
So I go into the apple store and I walk
up to one of the geniuses and I said,
yeah, Hey I need the little
fucking umbilical cord.
And they said that right there over the,
over there on the wall.
And I just walked up and I
grabbed five of them. Okay,
I grab five of them and I grabbed this
other cord where it was, you know,
where you can plug it into your phone
and someone else can also plug their
headphones in while you
plug your headphones in and
you can both listen to the
same song. And I did that, cause whenever
I'm on a plane and he's always like,
listen to the thought,
it was a great thong and I was just like,
I'll get that one for her,
right?
So I walk up to one of the dudes with the
fucking iPad and I just say, yeah, Hey,
I wanna I want to fucking,
I want to buy these. Right?
So they're all looking at me like, what
the fuck? Right? Why do you have so many?
It was two geniuses and one of the,
one of the people who just trying to
buy some shit there and it's one of them
finally goes to me. He goes, I gotta ask
Ya, how come you're buying five of these?
And I was like, uh, because I
know what kind of a moron I have.
And the dude was like, what?
I go, everybody's a moron,
so you've got to include me.
So you've got to figure out what
kind of moron you are. So, uh,
I'm the kind of moron that's going to
lose at least four of these in a year.
So I'm getting five.
And they all fucking laughed.
And I joked to her night somehow is
able to joke my way through the whole
fucking experience. I kept it light
and I, and I didn't lose my shit.
Uh Oh. Except when I got into it, that
one guy, I forgot when I was driving back,
this guy came barreling
up the street and I,
and I live on a street where it's
one of those streets where it's like,
it should be one way,
but it's two way.
And he came flying up
and I was rushing over,
so I just had to slam on the
brakes and just kind of gestured,
like really do it and it back up.
And then he pulls up alongside me and
he's big fucking Jaguar and he goes,
he goes, yes. Is there a problem?
He said, I go, I go, yeah,
I tried to stay calm. I go,
yeah man, I got you. You're driving too
fast through the neighborhood here, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. He
goes, I go, hey. I go, you
know, it's a one way street.
He goes, it isn't a one way
street. I go, yeah, but what
the car is parked, you know,
you know, I go, you coming through
here like 30 40 miles an hour. He goes,
this car won't go forward,
which I don't really know what that means.
Won't go 40 on this street. I have
no idea. I was just like, dude,
this kid's on this street.
And then I lied. I go, dude,
I have a kid just trying to
make my argument better. He
goes, I've got three kids.
And he holds up the fingers to like,
alright.
And then he just said something.
He goes, now do you feel stupid?
He said to me, he goes,
now do you feel stupid?
And I so I wish I could go back to that
moment and just say to him like, dude,
I always feel stupid,
but this has nothing to do with that dude.
You're driving like a fucking
maniac. You got three kids. Yeah,
I bet they don't live on this street. Shit
can't. And I was trying, I was trying,
cause I've done this before, people on
that street, I just speak in a slow turn.
It's going to, I got kids, you
know, I s line, I say kids plural,
just totally lie out my ass.
The reality is I don't want to have a
head on collision with somebody. So, um,
in our last couple of times I did it the,
even like the young punk kids and shit,
you know what the fucking hats that
match the fucking shoelaces. Even there,
they actually all, all right, cool. All
right. Sorry. You're like, yeah, cool.
No problem. You know, and uh, this guy
just wasn't having it. He just goes,
now do you feel stupid? And then I
just, once he said that, I, and I go,
fuck yourself.
We both drove away.
Uh, so that did happen on the
way over there. So anyway,
so I go to buy all of these fucking
things and I'm making fun of myself cause
guys, I'm really trying not, I mean,
it's funny when I do it on stage,
it's not funny when I do it in
real life or around the house,
I'm really trying to work on my temper.
So I was making fun of myself going, yeah.
And the kind of fucking moron that's
going to lose four of these in years.
So I'm buying five. So they all laugh
and the guy's like, all right. And I go,
what's that going to be
like $7,000 and he said, no,
it was like 75 bucks or something.
If he's little ass fucking wires,
five I'm like 25 a whack, a 20 a
whack, whatever the fuck it was.
But plus I had the other thing.
So I go to open my wallet to take out my
credit card and what is sitting in the
fold of my wallet is the fucking
attachment. It couldn't fight.
I must've put it in the same pocket.
And I just laughed. I go seek my days,
look at this. There it is now.
Now I got six, I'm a fucking war.
And they were just all
laughing and made me feel good,
even though they were laughing at me.
It just made me feel better that, uh,
you know, I dunno, I, I gotta be, I
gotta learn how to fucking do that man,
because I am a, I am a lot, you
know, I'm funny. On a podcast.
I'm funny for an hour, but after that
dude, I, I can be a lot to live with.
So anyways,
I'm working on myself.
I'm actually considering going
to speak to somebody and uh,
you know, cause I swear to God
like two things I want to do.
I want to just actually sit down and
maybe read some instructions on my iPhone
and actually make it something that I can
use and computers actually maybe learn
about them rather than screaming to
anyone who listened about road robots and
being microchipped, you know? And
then also I would like to, to, uh,
if I could just have the same sense of
humor I have about big shit when big shit
happens,
I do not flip out a little shit happens.
Like I lost a fucking little cord
on my phone. I fucking lose my shit.
So if I can just somehow,
you know,
not lose my shit in the car
and the technology thing,
those are my two biggest fucking goals.
If I could just laugh my way
through that shit, I would be,
I'd be a much better person. I've been
going to be a lot easier to deal with,
you know, um, and I'll just go after
it the way I go after other shit.
I've never really tried to fucking like
full on trying to fix my temper the way
I try to lose weight, workout, play
drums or whatever. By the way, dude,
I am in a fucking iron
maiden rabbit hole right now,
Clive for the whole fucking number
of the beast album. It's just,
I can't stop listening to it.
That and peace of mind. Um,
Nicko mcbrain I am fucking uh,
yeah,
that's where I'm at,
right?
No, but anyways, let me read a little
bit of a advertising here. All right.
Oh, here we go. This is becoming a new
favorite here. People are loving this.
Give gimme a loot crate everybody.
Now you're looking for
gear collectibles house.
Where in more from your
favorite pop culture franchises.
Bullet.
You're not,
you're listening to the
wrong advertisement cause
that's exactly what this is
about because these
people have you covered.
Loot crate offers a range
of Geek and Gamer items for
less than 20 bucks a month.
One to bring your loop to the next level.
Get a bigger box with an even bit with
even bigger lute with loot crate DX.
I gotta go fucking Google image.
Like what? What do they send you?
A bunch of like Spiderman
lighters and shit.
You know how big is this box?
But send up pops if you're,
if you're more the type to where
your geeky heart on your sleeve.
Then loot where our monthly wearables
and accessory subscription is the droids
you're looking for IC, they have
different options that she'll running up.
Your spine is in your imaginations.
It's loot crates. October theme
horror.
We're taking over 40 years of creepy.
Can't be bloody icons and putting
them in this month's crate.
Joda Rosa would love this shit.
Channel your best. He I've,
I'm a festival the other day,
had a Halloween to fucking shirt on and I,
I know I'm so while ago,
let me guess Joe,
that's the one you liked the best
and he laughed. He goes, it is.
And I go and you're aware of that cause
you want to argue with somebody that is
better than the first one. He just started
laughing. You think I'm a contrarian?
I tell you I pale in comparison of
that fucking shoulder lifts, man.
All right. Uh, channel from your channel,
your best final girl with items from the
walking dead nightmare on elm street.
Friday the 13th Texas chainsaw massacre
and Halloween you have until the 19th at
nine Pacific to subscribe and
receive that month's crate.
And when the cutoff
happens, then it's, oh,
make sure to head over to
www.lootcrate.com/burr and
enter a code bur bur are to
save $3 off any new subscription.
Yeah.
Today. Speaking of which, has
anybody watched a Luke cage yet?
I loved that. I brought that
fucking dude up. Why? Oh,
long time ago on this
podcast, man, that was my,
one of my favorite comic books was a
Spiderman and power man one when it was
about the NYP a f fire department.
A buddy of mine actually ordered
it on Ebay and got it for him.
And I hadn't seen that since
like 1978 or 80 when it came out.
And I watched the first episode.
I liked it.
They did the usual shit that they do with
superheroes. Like it, like, you know,
we just sit there like, well,
you fuck this chick already.
Why are you letting this
guy slapped me in the head?
They always have them do that shit
before they just fucking, you know,
throw somebody through a wall. I
watched that and I also watched, um,
a Westworld, which you want to hear
something hilarious. I love that movie.
When I was a kid, I loved
Yule. Brenner was huge. I mean,
nobody said draw like him when he drawl.
He did this fucking,
he just had the best voice ever.
Bad Ass with the fucking shaved
head and all that shit. Uh,
I love that movie to the point.
I remember like 15 years ago,
not 15, which will be like 10 years ago,
actually called my agent and I said, hey,
how much would it cost to
buy the rights to Westworld?
Because they just started redoing
all these things and I'm like,
there's no fucking way you could
make a killer movie out of that.
And of course they came back, it's
like, it's like nine zillion dollars.
I didn't realize it was a Michael
Craig Mu Book and all that shit.
So I obviously didn't have the money
and thank God I didn't have to fucking
rights to it cause I have to tell you,
I watched the first episode of Westworld.
They completely 100% took it to another
fucking level. Updated it. It's,
it's unbelievable. I actually liked that
pilot better than the Luke cage one.
Slightly better.
I thought the Luke cage one was the shit.
So now I got two new shows
back bay to fucking watch.
Definitely check those out. And
if you want a laugh, by the way,
I ran into a buddy of mine, uh, Willy
Garcia, who I'm seen in fucking forever.
He's still real deal is a fucking
hilarious comedian and he has a standup
special,
uh,
that he just put out and I wanted to give
him a shout out if you get a chance to
check him out. Uh, all right, let's get
back to the advertising here. All right.
Dollar Shave Club. Everybody,
uh, guys, you know,
to go to dollar shave club
for a fantastic shape,
what you probably don't know is that
they have other amazing products to the
quality is the best on the market.
Their body wash is great and won't dry
you out. I won't dry out your skin.
They're pre and post,
post shave stuff keeps your skin soft
and smooth. Do you know that
they made me a custom doctor?
Can have is easy shame potter.
They put the whole label
on it and framed it for me.
A really cool fucking
people at their company.
A dollar shave club's got stuff for your
hair, for your face, for your underpants,
uh, for everywhere you, you need
to keep feeling and looking fresh,
keep you feeling and looking fresh.
I just get worse every week with these.
Once you're in the club,
you'll see they've got the best
grooming products out there and they're
affordable right now.
Your chance to see for yourself why so
many people love dollar shave club. Um,
if you're not a member yet
and you've never joined,
now is the time you'll get your
first month of razors for free.
Just pay shipping. That's after that.
It's only a few bucks. Join today,
go to dollar shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr.
And the next one is how
many more of these are,
they're always trying to break them up,
but there's a lot. Let's do three and two.
All right. Three against two here, right?
Blue Apron, everybody? No, not all.
Not all ingredients are created equal.
This is like reverse JFK. Uh,
fresh, high quality ingredients.
Make a real difference. So it's important
to know where your food comes from.
Talk about your personal experience
with Blue Apron, the meal you cook,
the ingredients overall, how it tasted,
how it felt, it felt, cooking it,
et cetera. Well, I haven't used it yet,
but it sounds amazing. How about that?
That's my experience. I made a potato
pancake for the first time today,
gave it to my wife, put a little
salmon on it with some fucking,
what's that White Shit? Sour cream. And
a little bit of dill on top. All right?
Couple eggs over easy eggs over each.
And I gave it to her and I actually walked
out of the room because then I had to
make my eggs because how do you make
for fucking eggs over easy with the
standard fry and panty. Can't
do it. Somebody has to suffer.
So I came walking in afterwards and I
tried a little potato pancake and I got
that tastes pretty good. And
you know, and my wife said,
she said that was better than the
one that I had at brunch. Bam. Okay.
And I'm gonna tell you right now,
when you start making meals
like that field lady in the,
everything else goes to the next level.
All right?
I wish that there was a blue apron
when I was a kid. Uh, Christ,
we had to grow our own fucking potatoes.
These people going gonna bring them right
to your God damn door for less than 10
bucks per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with pre portioned ingredients to
make delicious home cooked meals.
What sucks the most when you
fucking make it a meal is taken out.
The little fucking measuring cop in
the little fucking teaspoon. Who is it?
A teeth did a table throat.
They eliminate all of that.
Blue Apron knows that when you
cook with incredible ingredients,
you make incredible meals.
So they set the highest quality standards
for their community of artisanal
suppliers, family run farms,
fisheries and riches. Uh,
whether it's Jap Japanese ramen noodles,
wild caught Alaskan salmon
or heirloom tomatoes.
Blue Apron is bringing you the best.
Customize your recipes each week
based on your preferences. Do.
This is a great fucking
way to get in shape too.
You don't have to go to the grocery store.
You're eating well.
You'd be making the ladies fucking like
you or the fellas. Waiter was hard, right?
Ladies, you know, not
trying to be massage.
Monistic not saying that a
woman should actually go out,
maybe cook her man and meal
every fucking leap year.
Choose delivery options to find your
needs. There's no weekly commitment,
so you only get deliveries
when you want them.
Each meal comes with a step by step,
easy to follow recipe card
and pre portioned ingredients.
And it can be prepared in 40 minutes
or less. That's the shit. Check this.
Check this week's menu
and get your first three meals for
free with shipping. With free shipping.
Go to blue apron.com/.
Burn.
I was picturing you guys squinting as you
try to hear me read this. Come on bill.
Get through one sentence
without stuttering. Uh,
you will love how good it feels and
tastes to create incredible home cooked
meals with blue apron. So don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/burr blue apron.
A better way to cook. All right.
And then we just got two more.
I'll read those later.
Um, is that my accent?
Is something done when the cookies done?
What's going on here
by the way? Uh, was I gonna
say, uh, I weighed myself today.
I'm in the buck seventies,
which is perfect to get my saw.
I want to be one 72 or think I'm going
to come in about one 75, but that's fine.
All right,
that is going to be fine.
Tipping the scales at one 75 as long as
I got that seven is the second number,
uh, I'll be all right. You
know what? I'll tell you,
I walk around weights
about two 10, two, 10.
If I could eat and drink the way
that I wanted to, um, by the way,
guess what came the other day?
Guess what came I ordered it back in June.
My Jaguar came. I fucking
picked it up today. I can't,
I'd like the Catholic guilt that I
fucking had that actually went out and
fucking, you know, did this,
but it wore off the second I
got behind the fucking thing.
I came walking into the showroom.
Dude, I ordered the color,
everything underrated under fucking rated.
Ordering a car.
You just go to the website,
everything that you want. You just
fucking order it. It's like blue apron,
except it's a fucking car,
right? Everything is perfect.
This fucking car. Oh my God.
It's, it's, it's fucking insane.
Um, I'll post Christian,
am I going to post it?
But I don't want to post a picture cause
no one has this color out here. Um,
I'll be like that chick driving around
in that pink Cadillac got fucking
corvette out here. But, um, even
Nia, cause she's all like, you know,
you know women dude, like when a
guy gets excited about some stuff,
I swear to God, it's like you're looking
at another woman. They always Gail,
he's gotta fucking take you down.
It's kind of cute and kind of annoying,
you know, but I'm mostly annoying and
way less cute so I, you know, whatever.
And uh, so I come walking
in, they got the whole day,
they actually backed it into the show
room and they put a car cover over the
fucking thing. Right. And they fucking
did the unveiling. They took it off to it.
It's just fucking, it's the
fucking, I don't give a shit.
It's the British racing green with the
black rims black grill. I got that,
that the fucking,
I had the analog gauges.
I didn't get all wheel drive cause I
wanted the rear end to kick out a little
bit. I got the rear
wheel, 390 fucking horses.
I'm going to take it over to Galpin
to get a new exhaust system on it.
Cause right now it's very,
are very refined sound.
I like a little more of a growl in it.
It's, it's dude, it is the fucking shit.
It's like what if Steve
McQueen drove a fucking, uh,
what a Steve McQueen drove a Jaguar and
had two kids because it is a four door.
Let's not get crazy. Let's
not get crazy. Um, dude,
it is. It's fucking awesome. And uh,
I love it because everybody out here
that has a four door sedan either has a
Mercedes, a BMW and Audi, and
then to a lesser case, Alexis,
but that's more of a younger
person's car. I feel, uh,
those cars are all fucking great and um,
I blown away.
It's like those have kind of become the
muscle cars of today are the four door
sedans, which is perfect. He
can actually put somebody in.
It's like an adult persons car.
MMM.
Oh my God. Like I absolutely
love with this car. So,
mmm.
It was fucking hilarious. And I got
the price. They wanted everything.
So then of course, dude, I just did, I
did everything right. I got these foot,
the floor mats are a,
they're not like the carpeted ones and
after a while they start wearing out and
everything.
I ordered these,
these like these rubber fucking
match that looked like the shit.
They say Jaguar on them and,
and they actually,
they're a little bit different color
black than the, than the carpet.
So they kind of pop a little bit.
I mean the car is the fucking shit and
it's going to kill me the first time
somebody opens a door into it.
But I was just thinking of the week Steve
McQueen drove that current bullet the
way those good old boys drove that
fucking uh, 69. What was the challenger?
They fucking broke one of
those every week. Fuck it.
He was supposed to drive it.
I remember fast and loud one time
they bought a Ferrari like f 40,
and the host of frame had been bent and
all that and they saw it and they were
all laughing. They were just
going like, you know what dude,
if you buy a car like this,
at some point it should look like this.
Obviously you shouldn't crack up your car,
but
they, they're meant to be
driven. But, um, I dunno,
I can't believe that I have that, that
nice of a car. So I want to thank him.
Stopped before I keep fucking gloating
about the car. Thank you to everybody.
Kevin came out to one of my shows and
watch my shit and told people about it
cause uh, you know, uh, yeah, I
wouldn't have that car if you didn't,
so thank you. And um, I'm actually
going to miss the Prius self. Um,
I actually selling it to a, uh,
to a friend of mine. So it's got,
it's getting a good home
and I got to tell you,
underrated the fucking Toyota Prius.
I had nine years,
85,000 miles on the fucking thing. I
changed the oil. I did everything on it.
It's a fucking,
that thing will go for 200,000 miles easy
if the next person changes the oil and
and on and all the lubricants
and all that type of shit.
Just regular maintenance
and all that type of stuff,
but they're just fucking great cars. He
knows. I also found that the Prius Dude,
when people, all my friends found
out that I was getting a new car.
I like half a dozen people go and
do what he doing with the Prius.
I'll buy it off you.
All these comics are loving it
because it has good gas mileage.
They actually have a decent resale value.
So the amount of shit that
those cars get mad, they're,
they're kind of a good investment.
The fucking cheap, the cheap on gas.
Like I know the whole fucking time,
every time the gas went
up and went fucking crazy,
I never paid more than like between 35
and 38 bucks is the most I ever paid in
the rest of the time.
It was about $27 to fill the fucking tank.
And, uh, when it would drop really low,
like when we would start producing oil
and then Saudi, the Saudis would be like,
Oh fuck, let's put them out of business.
And then they would overproduce, you know,
all the fuel and all that type of shit
and then it would just plummet. I mean, I,
there was, there were days I filled that
car up for like 18 or 19 bucks. So, uh,
I will definitely, I'll definitely miss
that thing. But this thing is just,
I'll just fucking, it's a beautiful
car. Red Calipers. Um, all right, let's,
let's, let's plow ahead here. Uh,
I have yet to watch the
Japanese Formula One.
I feel like I got you guys all excited
who are into that type of racing. Uh,
we're in a racing, I guess just
to say, and uh, and I've just,
I've dropped the ball on,
um,
Singapore and Malaysia and now Japan.
It's just because this fucking house,
some rent in this guy has like cable from
like the fucking 18 hundreds. And uh,
I got all the racist tapes.
I've watched Singapore.
I haven't watched Malaysia yet,
where our Lewis Hamilton was going to win
the race. And then for whatever reason,
his engine just fucking blew up.
I have no idea who won the Japanese one.
I haven't gone on the Internet.
I'm not looking at my Twitter feed.
I'm going to watch that tomorrow.
Um,
and me and he actually knew a couple
people that are over in Japan and I was,
you know, they having a baby or
something. So they have, they're doing a,
a baby moon, which I guess is
people before they have a baby,
they go some foot fucking place and uh,
you know,
they're in Japan. So I was seeing a
knee. It's hilarious. Typical guy, shit,
this is typical guy, women shit. Like
I say, Oh fuck. They were in Japan,
what will text so and so let them know
that the Formula One races there tomorrow,
man,
that he should go.
And then my wife's just like immediately
just looking at it like a check. Like,
yeah, she's not going to want to do
that. And I'm thinking like, yeah,
but he was fucking guys like in a
motorcycles and cars and off road.
But why the fuck would you want to
do go to a Formula One race in Asia?
Are you fucking kidding me?
I'm telling you if you,
even if you're not into that shit,
you got to watch the Singapore,
the Singapore race was fucking incredible.
Like they do it at night and then
after when, um, the city and beautiful,
right,
granted you're not allowed to do anything
and one of the guys spit gum on the
street and they fucking
detained him for six hours. Um,
I think they would just show it off
because when I was there, I was like,
I heard if you spit on the, on the
street, you get arrested. They go, Nah,
they'll give you a fine.
It's not like that.
And maybe they were soft
pedal in at the hotel.
She would be afraid to go out and
go spend some money. I have no idea.
All I know is this one of the fucking
guys from the Ferrari or Mercedes or
somebody spit some guns.
They fucking detained him for six hours.
Um, but anyways, they ranted
at night and that city is,
is gorgeous at night. It's beautiful.
And then when, uh, who won that one?
Nico,
when Nico Rosberg won that race,
they just shoot off all of these fireworks
bed and they go all the fuck out.
And uh, so I've yet to see
the, uh, the Malaysia one,
so I'm going to watch that
and the Japanese one tomorrow
if I have the time. Um,
all right. What else? What else did I want
to talk about? What else was a big, oh,
you know what I started to watch,
I started to watch before I
came down and I'm taping this, a
taping this Sunday night, I
started watching the Trump
Hillary debate. I mean, I,
I just still cannot fucking believe
these are two choices and a dude Trump,
I got to give it up to Trump. Dude,
that guy's one liners. All right.
Just for a politician.
Jesus Christ, he's fucking,
he kills the guy fucking kills.
He's great on his feet. He's,
he'd make a terrible president.
It's got no idea what the fuck he's
doing or what he's even talking about it.
It's just like the dope
verse, the Devil. Okay.
You know when I know everybody,
all that all fucking, you know,
that shit that he said, I just
got up, I grabbed by the pussy. I,
nobody just does that.
I felt bad for Billy Bush. You know,
he was just sitting there. He's like,
can you sit near some fucking
unknown 2005 you know, he's still
kind of unknown,
you know,
by a Billy Bush. I'm going to talk
about people who are in movies.
He's not in a movie. You know, he's a
talking head. Cut The guy a little slack.
He's sitting there with the
dawn that Don's talking shit.
He's talking about women. You know,
as guys do, I just walk right,
get up and I'd kiss me you. I
grabbed right by the pussy. You know,
Billy was just like this. Donald Trump,
you know, you get caught up in the face.
Oh yeah,
grandma.
He just went along with it. You
know, stay strong. Billy Bush.
She shouldn't have deleted you
to fucking Twitter account. Man,
he should have hung in there.
Fuck these people. They just,
they get mad for like three fucking days.
You know what I mean?
It's unfucking believable.
He's going to get more shit for that.
That fucking Hillary's going to
get for the Goddamn, you know,
classified fucking emails,
classified information
through her own fucking email.
Just some of that all goes into the rug.
I cannot stand and I can
tell when Hillary's lying
to she that smile. She does.
She can see it arise when she's lying.
Trump is like,
I just don't,
he's like a fucking cartoon character.
Like Alec Baldwin as Trump is more
believable than Trump as Trump.
That's how fucking nuts this
guy is. So I started watch it.
Oh Man. Trump had some funny
ones. He said to Hilary said,
if I was running this country,
you'd be in jail.
You know, it's funny to really see how
hard Donald Trump goes. This is a clip.
I don't know if he could still find it
that the first time Donald Trump was on
Letterman and he and Rosie O'donnell
had said something about him and he went
off on Rosie O'donnell and he goes,
well, you know, she's a degenerate.
And like it was just so over,
the top.
Letterman was laughing just going like,
Donald,
you just can't go around saying that about
people. And he's just like, yeah, no,
it's true. She's overweight.
He just fucking like,
just no filter. Just went
right after him. And uh,
he hasn't changed at all since
he's become a politician.
Having said that, like, I, you know,
it doesn't mean he's going to make a
good president. He's just, you know,
I can't get, I can't get past how many
overtly racist people love the guy.
And that's, that's always
a major red flag. You know,
what the fuck it is with
this fucking election.
It's like either got the guy that's
going to rally up the fucking neo Nazis,
the guy that rallies up the white guys
that think that there's something being
taken away from him, you
know, or you got Hilary,
you know, but he's actually, you know, Oh,
you've got Hillary
who's actually going to,
she's going to be in bed with the
corporate clients up at the fuck.
It's like a lose lose either.
You got somebody like rallying up this
fucking cess pool of people at the bottom
as far as mental. I'm not talking
financially, mentally speaking,
or you got Hillary who's just, you know,
she's going to give them their wars.
She's going to let the fucking robots
be made and I'll let you know. I Dunno.
I Dunno what that, oh my God, he's just
fucking and her fucking pants suits.
That's the only thing I like about her.
I love the pants suit. If I was a chick,
I would wear fucking pants
suits. I mean, you can,
you got to go with it at some point.
As a woman,
you reach your pants suits age
and you just gotta give into it.
That's like a man at some point.
You got to stop wearing your tank tops
and you've got to put on a sport coat.
All right. Try to keep the carbs
low, do the best you can. You know,
at some point you just get
to that fucking edge. So, uh,
I know a lot of you were like,
why didn't you bring up the Tom
Brady's back and all that type of shit.
Cause you know what,
we played the Cleveland Browns,
no disrespect but Cleveland browns of
where they're at and congratulations to
the fucking Indians.
You guys look like you're kicking our ass.
We're down o two I watched
like per Detroiters first
at bat and the plane landed.
So I missed all of that game,
uh, missing every fucking game.
Cause this guy doesn't have
a god. I mean, this is,
this is when I come in with
my brand new red sox hat. Um,
but I do know the Blue Jays
were up two games to none.
I don't know what's going on
with that series right now.
They were up three to two. The
last I saw in game three. But, uh,
Tom Brady's back. Gronk
Kowalski's back. We won, um,
buffaloes on a tear there looking good.
Uh,
I dunno, I just was just
great to see Brady back. Uh,
it's unbelievable. That whole fucking
thing that, that's I'm telling you,
I give it 20 years. And then NFL films,
when they look back on it and be like,
do you think that was fair?
Do you think it was fair that one of the
greatest players in the history of the
game had his entire fucking integrity
questioned by one of the biggest scumbags
to ever own a fucking team?
Um,
who basically hired a guy for an
in house investigation? I mean,
I still cannot, I cannot fucking
wait for that. How old will I be? 68.
Um, all right, Tom Brady will be 58. All
right. 60 minutes everybody. All right.
Hey, bill, I saw your tweet
about 60 minutes about a row.
About the talking robot piece.
Yeah.
Charlie rose was sitting there talking
to this artificial intelligent robot that
really moved bad, speaking
of fucking Westworld, right?
And he asks the robot what its goals were.
First of all that a robot would
have goals like a person. Okay.
And the robot said,
my goal is to one day be smarter
than human beings. So I tweeted,
you know, I basically treated,
please unplug that fucking thing.
Right? So he goes, um, I
come somewhere between,
unplug it and fuck it.
It seems like everyone knows
the machines will be our doom,
but I feel like everyone involved and
even everyone else just looking on has a,
but will they take over type of curiosity?
My question,
I don't know what you
meant by all of that.
My question to you is that if in 10 years
the robots are filling in his clerks,
had stores or working the lobby of hotels,
would you be comfortable as a customer
in those location all sleep? Also,
I highly recommend the new
Westworld remake on Hbo. Yes.
I thought that was
Netflix. My fault. Hbo, uh,
it's totally up your alley and I'm sure
you remember the original with Goodall
Yule Brenner House funny and said,
yeah, you hit the nail on the head.
I already talked about it. I loved
it. Um, this is what I think.
I actually think that, uh, that those,
um,
robots will make human beings obsolete.
I know that sounds fucking
crazy, but they will. Okay.
And they don't have to sleep.
They don't have to fucking do anything.
They'll outwork us and all that type of
shit and they're going to act like that.
Then we finally get to sit around
and chill out. Right? Like that was,
that was the big promise of all of this
technology that was going to be coming
out in the future. I mean, there's always
technology, but the, the newer technology,
it's technology of the future.
You know, the three day work week,
they used to make fun of that on the
Jetsons. Sally's three day workweek.
So brutal.
People are working more than they have
ever worked in their fucking lives in
this race to wa, I don't even
know what the fuck, why the kinks?
It's somebody. Please tell me
what the fuck we need robots for.
What do we need any of this shit for?
You know what I mean?
Like I feel like somewhere in like
the mid nineties that was good.
We advanced enough with cars travel
through advanced than us with medicine and
that type of shit. I mean basically from
1995 on if you fucking die. And then,
I mean,
yeah,
I mean, I don't know the amount of shift
did you could sidestep tuberculosis,
polio, all of these fucking things. Deed
all those plagues from back in the day.
They were all gone. I mean,
something, I don't know.
It's hard when it's somebody you know and
love or obviously if it's fucking you,
but like,
um,
okay.
I Dunno. I think the population, I've
always talked about it, I always,
it's a major fucking problem and
I don't know how they go. Like
I just feel like those things will come
along and they'll just be like, well,
you have those things that don't need to,
they don't need a flat screen TV.
They don't need any of that type of shit.
They can do the work of 10 people or
they say they can do the work of four
people. Then there's three extra
people out there isn't there?
Or there's forks to people out there.
Let's fucking cut this thing down by 25%.
I mean there's already too many
fucking people walking around.
You can have a bunch of
robots walking around too.
At some point something's got to give.
All right.
And I can guarantee you one thing,
robots are never forming a union, right?
All right.
They're not gonna so
I think there'll be smart enough
to not get him to do that.
But the greed of going after the dollar
and making one that's just a little bit
better, just a little bit better.
Like these fucking iPhones.
I think we could get ourselves
into a tough situation. And um,
okay,
here's a question I have. Uh, if
you kill a robot in the future,
like is that going to be
considered property damage?
At what point will that
actually be considered murder
one or murder two or robot
slaughter that they have all these
new laws, you know what I mean?
Like what if they make them
like what they're trying to do?
Like they probably try going to
make up fuckable at some point.
Like that fucking movie I saw
like a year ago. You know what,
if you go out and you fuck somebody
else's robot, you know like, Hey,
that's my robot. You just came in
my fucking robot. What the fuck?
Yeah.
Even though it's self cleaning and all
that shit, I can't fucking do that. Right.
Okay.
You just really opened it up and
fuck a can of worms there. Um,
alright. Clown sightings. Uh Oh shit.
And he is calling me.
My episode of the Simpsons is on
tonight is an on of doing the podcast.
I know he was supposed to be done.
It's hard than like a minute while
I can hit pause. Hey, come here.
I don't want to miss it. Puts
your eyebrows done. You're
like, what are you doing?
I don't want to miss it. Hey, how nice
is my car? It's very nice. It's awesome.
Oh,
I thought you when to go harder than that,
I think.
When you say it was a gorgeous, all
right. How good was a potato pancake?
That was delicious.
That was better than the restaurant.
Is it me or did you guys just have like
a distinct lack of fucking passion?
This is totally you like,
this is what I want you to do.
This is what I want you to do now for
the love of God. Go fucking do it.
And I'm sitting there like a little six
year old, mommy. Look what I can do.
All right, just hit pause. I'll
be up there in a second. Pause.
There's no DME. Oh, all right.
I know this guy's fucking depression era.
Fucking a cable. All right, I'm just
going to hit pause here and then we'll,
we'll come back and finish this.
Okay.
All right. You know, and after
all that, it wasn't even on Becky.
She fucking went off on how
great the potato pancake was.
She thought the car was gorgeous. You
see where they do? See what they do.
You see what they do? How all of a sudden
I'm fucking bragging a little bit. Ah.
Oh. It goes out. They're always trying to
fucking not knock it down a little bit.
All right, here we go. Clown sightings.
Okay,
you're listening to one right now. All
right. Clown sightings do have freckles.
Have you heard about this clamp?
Steria sorry.
Have you heard about this clown hysteria
freaks are dressing up as creepy clowns
and going out in public trying to scare
people.
Yeah,
I've seen those just search creepy clown
sightings as a bunch of and a bunch of
shit pops up.
Uh,
other people are now starting to go out
to go clown hunting and beating the shit
out of clowns that they see in public
now.
How the fuck do you go about doing that?
Isn't it?
There's like nine people in the
country that have done that.
Okay.
Let's go out clown hunting.
Wake where to clowns hang out.
Do they have a natural habitat? Is there
a bush she can go to the clown Bush.
Shake it a little bit. Throw some rocks
into it. Anyways, my question is one of,
yeah,
is if one of these clowns charged
that you what, what would you do?
Do you think it would be legal to run
over slash beat the shit out of the
fuckers that she'd,
you let the misfit go without harming him.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
I think at this point, I've seen
enough of those videos that somebody,
if one of them came running at me with
like dragging the body and it's just so
fucking over the top.
Uh,
I dunno, but you, you'd have to just out
of respect for you sell your own safety,
you'd have to fucking backup
or runaway. Yeah. I mean,
if a guy came running at
me because of my luck,
this would be the guy who isn't
fucking around. I'd be like,
Yo, what's up youtube? Worldstar whatever.
Take a fucking axe to the head.
MMM.
But, you know, I don't think
that you should go. I'm, I don't,
I clown hunting to me is hilarious.
Like,
how the fuck would you even remotely
begin to know where to look?
You know what I mean?
Like that was that thing for a while
where people putting train horns in their
vehicles and those people,
uh,
it should be prosecuted because,
you know,
my years of fucked that from years of
going to concerts and playing drums and
shit and like somebody did that
one time when I went by. You know,
it's funny watching people jumping ship,
but like it was close enough that it
did even more damage to my left ear,
which is fucked up.
And it's like that's something now that
I have to live with because this person
wanted to have a laugh. I mean the ring
and went away. But they definitely,
uh, and when you do shit like that,
I mean you are kind of asking,
you are asking for it.
You shouldn't do it like the other people.
You shouldn't go beat the shit on the
part that just fucking around trying to
make a funny video. I mean, you really
have to go beat the fuck out of them. Uh,
but when you do scare
somebody to that level, uh,
maybe that is a thing that
you can kind of expect.
I don't fucking, I don't know what
the rules of clowning is. All right,
now she's texting me saying
that it's starting. All right.
Hang on. Stop. And again,
every time I get momentum, you know,
we get a fucking hold and call.
It just kills the drive.
All right, now back again,
guess what? It wasn't even the
episode was the wrong episode.
There was a pre episode, so the episode
that they're going to show that I'm on.
All right. Anyways. Um, all
right. Waterproof electronics,
waterproof electronics. Alright. Uh,
dear Billy, what, what phone? Uh,
just to let you know,
the waterproof or water resistance
rating on electronics is bullshit.
The same goes for watches in
any other water resistant item.
Here's how they determine
the water resistant. I mean,
that makes sense. I mean,
you pour water on to anything it's going
to gradually seep through, right? Um,
although boats don't,
ah, that must be the dumbest I've
ever sound boats to. Okay. Uh,
they stick the phone in water and a
water filled tank and then increased the
pressure until the phone has problems.
The water in the tank is perfectly
still and the pressure stimulates,
stimulates the depth below sea level.
Um,
it's a bullshit tests because the water
you drop your phone into is probably spa
splashing all about and your phone is
going to move in the water as it sinks.
Um, if you don't drop your
phone into an ocean or a river,
you might drop it into the kitchen full
of detergent or some other situation
that isn't perfectly still water
pressurized under test conditions.
It's another marketing trick,
which technically legally
correct for the fine print,
but as bullshit for the day to
day life. Um, I dunno, I don't,
I don't,
it's gotta be better than the shit that
isn't waterproof where he just fucking
sneeze on it. It doesn't
work. Um, I know my watch,
I kept wearing it while I was doing cardio
and all of a sudden was fucked up and
it was just cause it was on my wrist.
I'm just sweating every day. It got wet.
Um, I don't fucking know. I have no
idea. It's probably all bullshit.
I know when they, when they do miles,
you know how much a car miles per gallon,
they drove it like they drive it like one
mile an hour with no headwind for most
of the fucking test.
Um,
clear what is going on with you buddy?
What is going on with you?
Go lay down Jesus Christ.
Are you allergic to the rug?
Every time he come down and you
start flipping out. All right. Um,
let me do these last couple of reads
and then I can finish with the questions
here. Sorry for the whole fucking pause
and then going out this week. Alright.
MVMT watches everybody
pronounced movement. Oh,
that's I'm supposed to say.
All right. Movement watches.
Everybody was founded on the belief
that style shouldn't break the bank.
The watchmaker's goal is to chart change
the way consumers think about fashion
by offering high quality minimalist
products at revolutionary prices with over
500,000 watches sold to customers in
160 plus countries around the world.
Movement watches have said solidified
itself as the world's fastest growing
watch company.
Um,
podcast slash radio evergreen copy.
Why would you tell me that?
What's the difference between this
and what you'd see on television?
I guess the company started by two
broke college kids that wanted to wear
stylish watches, but they
couldn't afford them. Okay.
So they started their own company.
That sentence never makes sense to me.
The two broke college kids, they
can't afford a watch. A stylish watch,
so they start a company.
Why can't afford a g five jet, uh,
dig all started jet company. How is,
how is this like,
how is this like how you started built
a following launched into podcasts,
youtube, radio, et cetera. I'm not
supposed to be reading this shit. Oh,
I'm supposed to be like, oh, these guys
remind me of how I fall, how I did it.
Uh, movement watches start.
I don't know where I am in
this copyright. Now. This is,
this is a shit show movement.
Watches start at just 95 bucks
at a department story. Uh,
you're looking at four to five and a
bucks moving movement figured out that by
selling online they were able to cut
out the middle man and retail markup
providing the best possible price.
All right, we're making sense again,
over 500,000 watches sold over
160 countries. Good for you.
Get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns.
Go up by going into movement.
watches.com/bird that's
MVMT watches.com/burr.
This watch has a really clean design.
Seriously. You got to love it.
If you put it on,
you're going to get compliments.
Now's the time to step up your watch
game without breaking the bank.
Go to MVMT watches.com/ [inaudible]
it's fucking hilarious, right? I want
a pure bred dog. I can't afford one.
So I started pure breeding dogs.
That's not even a good example. I mean,
wouldn't even know he'd fucking do that.
I wanted my own island,
but I couldn't afford one. So
I bought island. I started,
I started a company that made islands.
Bill, get it. All right. All right.
Stamps dot.
Yeah.
Ah,
man
is the easiest and convenient way
to get postage right from your desk.
Buy and print official US postage. Using
your own computer and printer was there.
Stop, calm. There's no guesswork.
They make it easy to get exact
postage for any letter, any package,
any class of mail, the instant
you needed. I you stand, stop,
calm to send out all my posters whenever
I'm selling them. Like next weekend,
Saturday through fucking Wednesday
in Washington DC. I'll have a poster,
the tuneup, the tuneup for my special, um,
sign up for stamps.com and use my last
name, birth for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer,
including a pote,
including postage and a digital
scale scale. Go to stamps.com.
Before you do anything else,
you
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com
enter bird. There's no reason to keep
going to the post office. All right? Okay.
Let's get back to the
fucking questions here.
Okay.
Um, let's see. Where the hell was I?
Okay. Water dear Billy, what phone?
All right. We did that one. Okay. Uh,
it's all your listings at ps.
Uh,
keep a little black book full of
your phone numbers from now on,
so you never lose another contact.
I'm actually doing that with
a couple of little red books.
I couldn't find the black ones.
All right.
Ceo a there.
Billy boss.
If you could become CEO of any
company for a couple of months,
which company would it be and what
would you try to change at Monsanto?
When I'd stop poisoning the food.
Oh,
Andy.
Monsanto just now on by bear.
Bear doesn't care. Uh, imagine, uh,
you have a few months so it's not like
you get to get fired day one for joining
apple and changing the name to
orange for selfish purposes.
Also you pick apple and can also pick
any other company you talk less about as
well. Ha Ha. Thanks for
everything. I think I answered
it. I think it was, I also,
my dyslexia kicked in and none of
those sentences made sense to anybody.
Those last two ones.
Okay.
What did it say? That one gives a shit.
Yeah, that's what I would do. I would,
I don't know. It would be nice
if the way corporations will run,
you know, it's some point you made enough
money and at some point you thought,
well hey, what would this be doing to
the environment? What would this be?
You know,
I actually heard that they're lobbying.
They got all these lobbies
going on right now.
Two,
make marijuana illegal again at the
state level because allegedly, uh,
prescriptions, medication
has dropped drastically, uh,
in states where marijuana
use is illegal and uh,
so they want to make it legal or illegal
again. Evidently my question is, is, well,
why not the big pharmaceutical
companies just start making weed. Yeah.
Okay.
You know, and phase out
these other fucking pills do
not work in ways, you know,
they don't work, you know, all
those fucking side effects. I mean,
it's fucking nuts.
This is shit that you can take literally.
That's just for something like really
basic. And if you get on it for a while,
if you come off it,
if you come off a too fast,
there's a chance you might kill yourself.
I mean,
they never had stuff like
that when I was a kid.
You know,
somebody was all over the place.
They were, they were fucking,
they will call the spares.
There was a fucking spares, man.
He's all over the fucking place.
You know what I mean?
I know it's a bad word in Scotland.
My apologies,
but that doesn't mean shit to us. And
you guys say cunt, every other word.
MMM,
yeah, I guess. Uh,
okay.
I Dunno.
That's one of those super depressing
kind of questions because when you really
think about it,
there's really no fucking reason for
our behavior towards one another.
You know what I mean? Um, I dunno.
I think it just comes down to
this just really, you don't,
you don't remember when you
watch like planet of the apes,
it was like the champs.
They were the fucking doctors.
Then he had the orange ones,
they were the old ones.
And then he had the gorillas and they
would like to fucking maniacs or whatever.
Um, which was sorta oddly racists.
They were the darkest of all the apes,
you know what I mean?
They were the worst and I guess what
the chimps were subtly supposed to.
I can see orange ones were supposedly
gingers and we were supposed to be the
best of people. I don't know. You can,
you can always read into all of this shit.
But like, I dunno, I think, I
think people are kind of like that.
You know what I mean? You got fucking
nice kind of, hey man, you know,
whenever you taking the Ambien man,
you know,
and then he just got fucking complete
psychos who will literally stab a baby in
the head to get another inch forward.
And I think those people
really succeed in life.
Like when you just don't
give a shit about, you know,
and I'm not saying I'm a fucking perfect
person cause I've done some horrific
shit, but I'm just saying, you know,
that's just the pain that I've
caused on an, on an individual level.
Forget about it. If you're doing it
at the fucking corporate level, um,
I dunno, I just love those people
go, well, if I didn't do it,
someone else would be doing it.
That, that's, that's usually a good,
that's usually a nice red flag that
you're doing something fucked up. But
MMM.
I really think that we are,
uh, this is depressing.
You might want to shut it off
now. I think we are the, uh,
there's a flaw in our design and
the way we are wired. We are,
it's inevitable that we're
going to destroy ourselves. Um,
it's just,
you know,
and I really don't think that it's
not even necessarily human thing.
It would be like whatever the
next thing on the food chain was.
If we weren't here,
it would be taking too much and it,
and in its own fucking way would be
fucking up the balance in nature and all
that type of shit. But uh, I
don't know if I 100% believe that,
but I just look at it that way
cause then I don't, I can just,
I can deal with some of the
shit like a, that I see.
I do have to say though,
this presidential election in these two
choices is one of the most depressing
fucking things. Uh, I've been around it
in a long fucking time. I can't believe,
I just can't fucking believe it's a
reality TV show star or the fucking devil
who, oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy.
All right. Halloween costume.
Just get off that topic.
Hey Bill.
When was the last time you
dressed up for Halloween? Uh,
two years ago I dressed up as John Bonham.
Um,
if you had to go to one of
these celebrity dresser parties,
like we're Heidi Clume goes all out
every year and shows up looking like an
extra from the Tom Cruise movie legend.
What would you dress up as a,
when millions of women look at
a US weekly at the hair salon,
who will they see Billy
red face dressed up as a,
when they get to the celebrities wear
stupid costumes just like us a section.
Um,
well first of all,
those are all the beautiful people
self. I'm out. I'm not in that section,
so I don't think they were,
let's just say all the beautiful people
got hit by a truck and it got all the
way down to I, you know, was
in that thing. Let's see.
I, I would probably John Bonham,
I've done that one enough.
Who would I dress up as?
Okay.
Somebody like debts known but sort of
obscure because you only to be the like
the 12th Douche to show up,
you know,
dressed as like Donald Trump
is going to be like the,
everybody's doing that or Hillary,
you don't want to dress up as Steve Jobs.
I still think he's fucking known well
enough. You gotta you gotta dress up like,
uh, uh, let's see here.
Who'd be a good one? Who's a
good fucking, they were the sh,
you know what I mean? Like if you were
going to dress up like somebody and uh,
okay,
you know what? You got me,
this is how I would have,
this is something you just
can't fucking pull this gem out.
Like, you know what? Dressing up like
the professor instead of Gilligan.
It's basically that formula, but not
that example. You know what I mean?
Like who the fuck lost
the last presidential race
Obama ran against? Who Was it? Mccain?
I don't know. But Tina Fey
did the fucking, the chick,
she did that one to death.
I Dunno,
you know,
some bill Bellacheck might be a good
one for as well known as he is. I'm,
Tom was out in here in la
and I just dressed like him.
I think people would love it.
A hoodie with the fucking cutoff sleeves,
you just have it up, you know, maybe him.
Okay.
You know what I, I would
go, Vince Lombardi,
maybe an old football
coach go out as Tom Landry,
but I got to pick some with a
fucking blockhead like mine,
something like that.
Something along those lines rather than
like the hacky once, you know, want to go.
And I was fucking Chewbacca. Anything
from star wars, any superhero.
I mean that's just fucking lame.
Trump, Hillary, that's fucking lame.
Obama, you gave you me, you're going to
get in trouble for being in blackface,
so you got to leave them alone. Ah, Shit.
That's a good question.
I go out,
I was like Phil Rudd Drama for ACDC
and people say,
who are you? I'd say Phil Rudd. And
they, and people said, who's that?
And I'd be like, Ugh, you gotta be ashamed
of yourself and you just walk away.
So you get to like have a cool costume
and scold people. There's a way to go.
You know, pick somebody who
people you, you feel should know,
but they don't know addresses Clive birth.
Um,
I dunno. I don't know what the fuck
I'm talking about anymore. All right.
That's the podcast for
this week. Everybody. Uh,
I'm going to watch those
Formula One races. I'm hoping
the red sox can come back.
I just want to be able to sit
down and watch a fucking game.
I don't know anybody on the team.
I know Petrolia and I know
big poppy and when he leaves,
I'm just going to know Pedroia um,
plus this one Cleveland fan
was like fucking talking
shit to me. A buddy of mine,
he's going to call fucking,
you know,
Tito is playing a chess game with the
fucking red sox and I jokingly wrote back
like, yeah, you don't need to talk to me.
You don't need to talk to a red
sox fan about Tito playing chess.
I saw him play chess a few times when
he was here and it just completely went
over the guy's head.
You know what I mean?
I Dunno sometimes just sitting
there going like, hey man,
you guys are looking pretty good.
Nothing
bullpens, dorming, any were fucking
where juries and then meals.
I was like,
I hope you can stone when another one is
60 years. I was fucking rooting for you.
Um, AH, fuck. Do I have
another phone or tomorrow
I have one folder is when you call in.
Oh Shit.
I'll get up that early for
these guys. Hey, I'm going
to be on the sports junkies.
I love these guys. I haven't talked
to these guys in fucking forever.
The sports junkies, I remember lurch
would always be so fucking sitting there.
All splay old.
Six foot 10 guy always in sweatpants.
I'm going to be calling in.
It's 6:20 AM march is nine 20 eastern
time going to be calling that and that
gets, it's to promote my
shows at the national theater.
October 15th through the 19th 15 1617
1819 five nights running my fucking mouth,
getting ready for my special.
And then I do the special and that
my fucking year is basically over.
Um, I'm just going to edit the
rest of fucking season two.
I'm going to be doing comics,
come home and Boston and uh,
that's going to be about it. It's
going to be about it. All right,
well that's the podcast for this week.
Once again,
I really meant that about being able
to buy that car. Um, thank you for,
to everybody come out to my shows
throughout the fucking years and uh,
that's it. Jacksonville. I hope you guys
can dig yourself out nice and quicker,
but the weather's nice now.
Now that it's fucking over. Um,
and I help the insurance companies
don't fuck you too bad. No,
but either way when you can go back to
that city again. When I get my next hour,
I'm definitely going to come through cause
Jacksonville is always going to be on
my tour schedule. I always have a good
time when I go, when I run through there.
And who's kidding who? I got to get
back to Gainesville to make that up,
which I think I might be
doing in February. Cause uh,
in February I'm going to be
going to the Daytona 500.
I've always wanted to go to that thing
way back. Since we're rusty Wallace,
Harrigan, Darrell Waltrip,
Cale Yarborough, Bill Elliot,
Rusty Wallace,
right day he'll earn are,
who else ran back then? Dick trickle.
Um, all right. That's the podcast.
Fuckos I will talk to you.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
I really had to try not to make a noise
when I sat up there doing that shit.
All right.